i've been using the apple watch series 7
for one week now and even though i was
extremely underwhelmed with it when
apple announced it and a bit
disappointed once we did our hands-on
comparison against the series 6 the 5
and the 4 since then it has actually
surprised me in multiple ways in this
real world honest review i'm gonna be
skipping most of the specs since you've
likely seen them already anyway and
focus on what stood out to me most when
i was using this watch day
both the positives as well as the
negatives and i'm gonna cover all the
little details that most reviewers
didn't touch on at the launch date of
these watches when a bunch of reviews
came out and then finish off if the
series 7 is actually worth it or if you
should just wait for the series 8. i've
been wearing apple watches ever since
the very first series 0 and i've
upgraded every single year until last
year that is where the series 6 was such
a minor update for me personally that i
broke that cycle and ended up returning
the series 6 and just using my series 5
for a second year the new series 7 is
yet again an iterative upgrade and many
would argue that it's an even smaller
upgrade this year so why am i liking it
so much more this year last year the 6
got a 20 faster processor a u1 chip a
compass the always-on altimeter faster
wi-fi and a sometimes brighter display
which was my biggest complaint against
the series 5. now that wasn't enough for
me to upgrade so what does the series 7
offer well there are no new health
features the storage is the same and
even the s7 processor is just a
rebranded s6 apple even said that the
battery life is the same but we know
that their consistent yearly claims of
18 hours can vary greatly in real world
use and that is exactly what i
experienced the same thing goes for
other things they don't mention such as
the taptic engine now before i cover the
screen and the software let's talk about
that engine almost nobody talks about
this but i found this to be a huge deal
in real world use apple has been great
at being able to nudge you about
notifications without other people
hearing but i found that sometimes it is
just too weak the same thing goes for
using it as an alarm to wake me up who
knows maybe i'm just a lot less
sensitive to the vibrations compared to
other people but one thing is for sure
the series 7 has a much stronger tactic
engine then my series 5 and the earlier
apple watches and after using this for a
week and then putting on my series 5 for
today it is a substantial difference
this makes me want to start using it as
my daily alarm which i rarely used
before and that along with the faster
charging and better battery life will
likely push me over that edge apple
really focused on the faster charging
feature with this watch and that just
eight minutes gets you a full night of
sleep tracking and that the watch
charges 33 faster as well now battery
life has always been an issue with apple
watches and though most of the time i
can get through a full day some days
when i'm really using it more my series
5 will die before bedtime when i saw
that apple quoted the same 18 hours of
battery life i was disappointed
especially after they said that the
screen is 50 percent thicker i thought
how often do people break their screens
i am super tough on mine and is never
been an issue it's been super strong but
many people complain about battery life
so much so that people will actually go
and disable the always-on displays to
help so why not use the extra space for
a bigger battery instead of a thicker
screen well it turns out that apple did
increase the battery capacity with these
new watches the 41 millimeter has the
biggest improvement but it is still
there with the 45 millimeter that with
the fact that the chip is more efficient
than my s5 and this watch is brand new
made a noticeable difference in battery
life and now that we have fast charging
i will end up using sleep tracking as
well
now the other big thing they pushed is
the display at first glance it seemed
nothing like the 20 larger that they
talk about and their product images show
online on their website i found that it
really depends on what apps and which
watch faces you use some have almost no
difference but others are very
noticeable in reality the biggest screen
is not a reason to upgrade but apple's
software limitations might actually be
now i personally really like the new
contour face which is designed to
maximize the screen size and really show
that off and it uses the light
refraction from the curved glass of the
screen now sure they could have added
this to the 44 millimeter models from
the past but it wouldn't look as cool so
i understand why they might not want to
do that but the modular duo watch face
is a serious ripoff this phase allows
for two full width really detailed
complications like stocks for example
and none of that info bends into the
screen curve like with the contour face
so why not add a ever so slightly
smaller version for the older watches
well like i said this is a rip off i
think it's just so that people would
have another reason to upgrade now of
course we do have the world time and the
portrait watch faces which are available
on older models and they look good but
once i got used to the larger screen of
the seven compared to my five they
looked uh quite a bit smaller on the
five especially the portrait one now i
also noticed a few other differences
that apple didn't mention with the
display one is contrast where the series
seven has much less reflectivity and
better contrast than my five which is a
great thing and the other one of course
is the brighter display when it is
dimmed i hated that with my five like i
said it was my biggest disappointment
and the six it promised two and a half
times brighter display when it is dimmed
but it turned out that that was only
outdoors if it is very sunny and
personally if i'm outdoors i'm not
trying to slowly kind of glance down my
watch and see the time i can move around
a lot more freely now the 7 promises to
be 70 brighter and the key thing is
indoors when the watch is dimmed and
that is definitely noticeable especially
with particular watch faces the portrait
watch face shows almost no difference
but more minimal ones like california
are dramatically brighter it's almost
like the series 7 doesn't even dim or it
barely dims when you're using this apple
thank you for finally fixing this listen
to my complaints from years ago and
making the always-on display much more
useful now onto the final software
features that make a big real world
difference and that is the keyboard now
i'm not sure about you guys but i hated
typing or to be more accurate scratching
or sketching on the screen with the
apple watch in order to write something
it is so slow annoying that i ended up
never really using this and i relied on
voice which does work well but it is not
always possible for example in loud
situations or when you need to be quiet
well we now have this new full keyboard
with swiping that actually works quite
well once you get used to it once again
i do think that they could have made
this work on a 44 millimeter watch but
of course apple is not giving that to us
these legitimate upgrades and software
limitations with the six might actually
make it worth upgrading from a six to a
seven if money is not an issue for you
at all but for most people you shouldn't
do it now coming from a 5 though where
your battery was worse from the start
and it is now wearing out like mine is
at for example 86 capacity it's now a
way more logical thing to upgrade to a 7
than i thought at the launch of this
watch and of course for series 4 owners
it's an even bigger upgrade the main
question is if you should wait for the
series 8 which will almost certainly be
fully redesigned well if you're on a
budget and you only upgrade your watch
every 3 to 5 years i would say try to
wait another year if you can
now if you upgrade more often or if you
might not like the upcoming square edge
design i say go for it by the series 7.
the improvements are a lot bigger than i
expected at the launch of this watch and
overall the series 7 is a much more
useful upgrade than i thought before at
least for me personally if you are
wondering how the se compares to the 7
go ahead and check out our full
comparison right over there and click
above to subscribe if you guys want to
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers and to see more videos like
this one this has been max and i will
see you in the next video